you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast automated single celled
Association of primary tumors and
patient-derived xenograft I am QD Oracle
a brute and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by labyrinth comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by Milton a
biotech Milton e biotech is a global
provider of products and services that
advanced biomedical research and
cellular therapy the company's
innovative tools support research at
every level from basic research to
translational research to clinical
application this integrated portfolio
enables scientists and clinicians to
obtain analyze and utilize the cell
Milton E biotechs technologies covered
techniques of sample preparation cell
isolation cell sorting flow cytometry
cell culture molecular analysis and
preclinical imaging there more than 25
years of expertise span research areas
including immunology stem cell biology
neuroscience and cancer and clinical
research areas like hematology graft
engineering and a phoresis the company
also offers comprehensive scientific
support consultation and expert training
to learn more about Milton e biotech
visit w-w-w LT biotech comm troy start
there are a few instructions we want to
hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by using the green two and a button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome JT Poirier PhD an assistant
laboratory member at Memorial
sloan-kettering
Cancer Center medicine doctor parties
lab focuses on the development of new
patient derived xenograft models and
experimental lung cancer therapeutics
during his career he has developed a
wide range of skills in laboratory based
and computational research having these
hybrid skill sets positions him to
operate at the interface between the
world of the wet lab and that of the
high-performance computing cluster dr.
parries research has focused on the
genetic and epigenetic landscapes of
small cell lung cancer therapeutic
targeting of the dll 3 and development
of oncolytic virotherapy s he has also
established an overseas an active
program in patient-derived xenograft
development and characterization through
this program he has developed a series
of best practices for genetic
characterization of human xenografts
grown in mice and biomarker validation
in PDX i will now turn the presentation
over to dr. Parr a thank you this
presentation is going to cover one
specific aspect of our research program
that we're finding that we use fairly
often and that's automated single celled
Association of primary tumors and
patient-derived xenograft there are two
learning objectives for this
presentation one is I want to cover the
advantages and challenges associated
with using PDX models for cancer
research as well as solid tumor
dissociation methods
compatible for downstream single-cell
applications such as flow cytometry
immune attack netic enrichment and
single-cell sorting so just one slide
introduction about my lab and my
research interests my interest really
focused on the lung and lung cancer lung
cancer is is a extremely lethal and
devastating disease and it's a disease
that we focused our research on starting
with a important clinical question then
taking this to the basic science
laboratory performing validation studies
and then and then hopefully bringing
this full circle back to a back to the
clinic
and in the basic science applications as
you've heard my lab does a lot of
genomics epigenomics and transcriptomics
were recently doing more functional
genomics using genome scale CRISPR and
we've traditionally done a lot of basic
biochemistry and molecular biology in
the validation phase I'm very interested
in high fidelity cancer models
particularly in mice basic pharmacology
and more recently molecular imaging and
now in the clock aside I partner with
clinical collaborators for early phase
clinical trials retrospective biomarker
studies and diagnostic assay development
this talk is divided into a few
different parts I'm going to start off
by just giving a short introduction to
patient Dr Cena graphs we think about
Sina graphs in mice is taking a couple
of different general approaches the
standards in a graph model for several
decades has been to take primary tissue
from a patient from the clinic establish
a new and more to life cell line grown
in cell culture and then graph those
cells into immuno compromised mice by
contrast patient derive Sina graphs
never are grown in vitro and one of the
major differences here is that there's a
selection process when bringing cells
from the in vivo environment to the in
vitro environment it is reversible when
you bring it back to the mouse and we
think that this is driven by changes in
oxygen tension growth substrate growth
factor and nutrient gradients among
other things so my lab has been really
focused on using patient-derived
xenograft as a tool for concept
validation in preclinical in a pre
clinical setting and using that
information in a push-pull mechanism
with the clinic so there are a number of
different mouse models for cancer and
they all have their we think they're
really complementary and each one has
their own
disadvantages I told you about
traditional cell line Sina graphs these
are human cell lines they're relatively
fast and cheap to work with once the
cell line is established and they're
fairly easy to engineer with
lentiviruses and and other similar
technologies patient Dr Cena graphs are
similarly human they're relatively easy
and cheap to work with we think they
maintain a slightly better more high
fidelity model of primary tumors but
they're generally much more difficult to
work with than cell lines unit graphs I
won't be talking about these today but
I'll just add that of course they're
also genetically engineered mouse models
or gems they have distinct advantages in
being used in immunocompetent settings
having more heterogeneity heterogeneity
and in the cells that are initiated
they're much more facile engineering of
the genomes in these models of course
you can take cells from these these gem
models and engraft them directly into
sin genetic Mouse for which sometimes
called a gem derived allograft or GDA
this presentation is really going to
focus on PDX but some aspects I think
will also be applicable to traditional
cell lines ena graphs and mics I just
want to illustrate on this slide that we
think about tumors they're really a
composition of cells that include the
tumor cells themselves but also various
cells of the immune system that will
infiltrate the tumor the vascular
network that brings nutrients and oxygen
to the tumor associated fiberglass and
other cells and that the tumor mass
itself is made up of human cells that
are the cancer cells themselves but all
of these support stromal cells come from
the host which in in the experimental
setting is mouse and this imposes
several challenges one is that it can be
difficult to control the tumor growth
variance within treatment groups during
therapeutic studies you
and have some tumors that grow faster or
slower
another problem with having admixed
mouse and human cells is that the
nucleic acids that you extract from both
tumor are actually both human and mouse
origin and I'll show you that the
mirroring component can actually make up
a very significant fraction of the
nucleic acids that you extract the other
aspect that can be challenging is that
manual disaggregation may not be tagged
rly consistent for single cell
sequencing applications I'll show some
QC data some of our initial experiences
with single-cell rning see when we first
started working with pd x our general
approach was we would put some tumor
tissue into a petri dish like this in a
small amount of media and we would take
a razor blade and just chop up the tumor
into as fine pieces as we could put this
through a nylon mesh strainer and then
hopefully that would dissociate the
tumor to a point where we could inject
this into mice to establish a cohort and
over the last few years when I
established my lab at sloan-kettering
we've been using an automated method to
try to make this process more consistent
and to illustrate the instrument that we
use for a dissociation which is a Milton
II octa max gentle dissociate er I have
a 15-second video cued up if you could
play it please
you
basically put the tumor into these
disposable tubes we had an enzyme mix
other and the tissues then get
disaggregated in a programmable and
reliable way and I'll just show a couple
of quick slides about the effects that
this can have in animal experiments so
you know a few years ago before we
started using this approach it was
sometimes difficult to control
variability within treatment groups so
I'm showing here tumor growth curves
from an in vivo Zenon graft experiment
using the same PDX line and on the Left
we had really you know very little
variability within individual groups and
this made it really after only a few
days of treatment with an experimental
therapy to see if there's a significant
difference in in growth between these
two groups but the same experiment
repeated had a much higher variability
and was very much more difficult to
interpret and we wanted to have some
better control over this by dissociating
the tumors in a reliable way so that
we're not having some mice that get more
or less tumor tissue than others this is
a in vivo experiment from a recent
publication where we used autom
automated Association I think you can
appreciate that the in this very large
experiment the variability is within
groups is is much much smaller the other
approach that we've been or the other
application that we're finding for this
association is in quantitating the
amount of mouse stromal cell
contamination that there is and actually
doing some testing approaches to remove
that those contaminating cells so I told
you that the tumor zina graft is made up
of a varying human cell component and a
mouse cell component and so what we
wanted to do is be able to take a
xenograph from a mouse perform automated
Association
and then study these different
components independently so one of the
first things that we did was just ask
the question in our lung patient drive
scene and graphs how much you know what
percentage of the tumor was actually
made up of mouse cells versus human
cells and on the far left you can see a
flow cytometry experiment we did where
we stain the cells we double stay in the
cells either with an epithelial marker
in this case F cam or a mouse specific
marker h2k D and you can see that once
you get a single cells associated
population you can really separate the
cell types into two really distinct
groups and this let us do a couple of
things one is it it let us enumerate the
number of cells that belong to each
class but it also gave us access to the
potential to use flow cytometry to sort
these two populations and obtain pure
reference populations of either want
we've also been using a technique that
was developed by Jim Eshelman and Sarah
Whelan who are former colleagues at
Johns Hopkins that uses a PCR amplified
based approach to actually quantitate
from a mixed pool of nucleic acids how
many or what percentage of the nucleic
acids came from a mouse genome versus a
human genome and in the middle here is
just shown two different Peaks the blue
peak is from the human cells and the
orange peak is results from a PCR
product from the mouse cells and so we
were able to by quantitating the peak
height figure out how much contamination
there was and I was gratifying to see
that once we started to calculate the
amount of contamination that in the lung
adenocarcinoma PDX we saw that the
tumors were more diffused and more
infiltrated with stroma than for example
in small cell lung cancer and this
really reflects what the histology of
these tumors looks like
and part of why we started to think very
hard about this problem of contaminating
mouth cells was that we were starting to
it was our endeavor to try to have his
careful molecular characterization of
these Sina graphs as we could and we
wanted to implement a targeted
sequencing assay that's now used in the
clinic at our institution called msk
impact to characterize these samples and
I won't go over all the details of this
assay because it's published but the
concept is that biotin elated probes
allow for hybridization in solution with
targeted exons from a small number of
cancer genes I think it's now more than
500 or 400 cancer genes
these are sequence to very high depth to
allow for high sensitivity and then
mutation calling pipeline was able to
call mutations so this is an example of
a tumor that sequence compared to its
normal and we're looking at just one
exon from the EGFR gene that harbors the
activating l85a2 our mutation and this
is showing the sensitivity of this
approach to detect this this activating
mutation in in cancer cells I won't go
over this but this is just a slide
showing that some of the major cancer
genes that are covered by this panel and
I'll also just note that this panel can
be used to call copy number as well so
this was really attractive to us and we
wanted to be able to apply this
sequencing approach and other sequencing
approaches like whole exome sequencing
to our growing library of
patient-derived xenograft and one thing
that all of these technologies rely on
is alignment of nucleic acids at short
reads to a reference genome so I already
told you that these tumors are composed
of nucleic acids from both the human
cells but also from the mouse genome and
what I'm showing here is just a cartoon
that describes the problem of trying to
sequence the mix
halation of two different species so if
you envision aligning reads from a
purely human sample to either the hg19
human genome or the mm10 mouse genome
I think it's intuitive to think that the
majority of these reads are going to
align very well to the human genome we
also know that there are conserved
sequences between human and mouse and
some human reads may actually align to
the mouse genome which is shown with the
glue reads overlapping orange but I
think what happens when you replace a
portion of those human reads with some
contaminating Mouse reads is you have a
converse so some of those reads never
align to the human genome and some of
those reads will align better to the
human genome and they do to the mouse
and this results in really two
complications one I think you can
appreciate is the loss of total deaths
it reads that align to the human genome
but also this is a problem to have Mouse
reads that are partially mapping to the
human genome and I'll illustrate exactly
the problem that this causes in
real-world samples later but for now
take my word for it that this can cause
a very high rate of false positive
mutation calls so you want to get rid of
these reads and we took two approaches
to this and you know one traditional
approach had been to do a to pass
mapping approach where you you map all
of your reads to the human genome then
you map all of your reads to the mouse
genome you set cut-offs for identity and
then you eliminate the reads that map
better to a human than Mouse clen to
human we've been taking a different
approach where that we call a hybrid
genome approach that does a single pass
mapping against a hybrid genome that
includes all human and all Mouse
sequences and then after the mapping is
done we just discard reads that map
better to the mouse or preferentially
map to the mouse
and we want to benchmark this approach
and using his real-world a sample as we
could and so we turn to the Illumina
platinum genome since these are a trio
of individuals that has been sequenced a
very high depth on an Illumina high-seat
mm system so these are 200 X deaths for
one of the samples it was there was a
technical replicates oh it was sequence
to 200 X death twice and because this is
a trio there's very high confidence
snips being able to call very high
confidence it's called for for one of
the samples you know was phasing from
the two parents so we started by
downloading these genomes and what we
did was align them either to the human
genome which is on the x-axis or to the
hybrid genome which is human and mouse
and then we examine what the what the
read depth was at every base and what we
were concerned about is what's
highlighted in this triangle which is
basically we wanted to estimate the
potential loss of deaths at different
locations in the genome because we
didn't want regions of the genome to go
dark because of too high homology
between human and mouse and our
conclusion from this was a while there's
some loss of depth in certain low sigh
it's not the loss of depth is not so
great as to prevent accurate mutation
calling and we can still have 90 greater
than 98% of the bases in the genome are
callable which is about the same
fraction whether you're looking at a
hybrid genome or looking at the human
reference alone so these in silico
experiments kind of convinced us that
this could be a usable approach but we
wanted to really get at what the
operational effect of mouse
contamination was on genome sequencing
pipelines so we turned to this great
tool that was published in Nature
Methods in 2015
called BAMF surgeon and this tool was
created as a way to generate gold
standard reference files with mutations
in known locations and this was used as
a way to basically benchmark different
mutation calling algorithms in the ICGC
mutation caller shootout and what we did
the advantage of this is basically it
takes an already aligned bam file it
also takes a number of genomic loci
where you want to insert a mutation and
it inserts those mutations and then
remaps the reads that contain the
mutation so what you end up with is a
bam file that has been altered to have
mutations in known locations and so it
allows you to then go back and ask if
your mutation caller is able to recover
those mutations and to what extent your
mutation caller calls mutations that
don't exist and so we came up with this
pipeline that we internally called the
Mouser and this diagram is a little bit
complicated but what is really being
shown here from the top is that we start
with a list of single nucleotide
variations that we were interested in
studying and so these were a list of
known mutations at no Llosa that we
wanted to to spike in and then we
started with the technical replicates of
one of the Illumina platinum genomes at
200 X depth and 40 X genome from the NSG
Mouse and using these three sequence
genomes what we did is basically seed
the single nucleotide variants and one
of the technical replicates into BAM
surgeon to insert mutations and then use
what we call the Mouser to randomly mix
in a variable amount of mouse genome
sequences so what we end up with is on
this row what we called a virtual tumor
the X virtual PDX also at 60 X with some
amount of contaminating mouse reads and
then normal at 30 X so all we did here
was down sample and basically we ran
these into mutex called single
nucleotide variants with mutex and then
we used a comparator algorithm to
compare the mutations that we put in
there artificially and the mutations
that we were able to get out in the end
and what this pipeline ended up spinning
out for us was this figure which is is a
small figure but it says a lot of things
on the x-axis is basically the amount of
Mouse DNA contamination increasing from
left to right on the y-axis is the f1
which is the harmonic mean between
sensitivity and specificity so the range
here is from 0 to 1 and 1 means that you
have hypothesis activity and specificity
the lines here are showing mutations
that are inserted at different variable
frequencies so the blue line we're
looking at a mutation that is spiked in
at roughly 5% bearing a little frequency
versus around 40% variable granule
frequency in orange the open symbols
here are looking at exome or exonic
territory whereas the close symbols are
looking at the same variant frequency in
whole genome territory so I think we
took a couple of things away from this
one was that at 30 X to 60 X depth 5%
very low frequency you weren't really
going to be able to reliably call those
mutations anyway high varying a little
frequency you can tolerate a lot of
Mouse contamination but the low
frequency variants in the 10 to 20
percent range the ability to call those
mutations really drops off as your
content Mouse contamination increases
and we think that this is really driven
by loss of overall total depth so
as your sequencing depth drops as your
sequencing depth drops you really lose
the sensitivity and specificity so to
mitigate this we realized the only thing
that we could really do here was to get
rid of the mouse stroma and so we
decided to audition different techniques
to be able to remove these these cells
so what we did was you know dissociate
some tumors and then audition different
different approaches to purify out the
tumor cells and then uses our gold
standard quantitation by a PTI replica
amplicon based approach so what we did
will for five different PDX was compare
the presort
which is the input to fax sorting which
we considered to be our gold standard
then we looked at a negative depletion
method which pulls out the mouse cell a
mouse cell depletion cap which pulls out
the mouse trauma where we looked at
positive selection approaches which
would pull out the tumor cells of
interest and our conclusion based on
this is that fax is a great way to
purify yourselves but we really like
this mouse cell depletion approach we
think it's much more powerful you know
for removing cells and I think that our
conclusion especially looking at MS klx
27 was that if you're looking at a model
that initially has a fairly high Mouse
contamination for the start it's really
hard to using positive selection pull
out a very pure population but with a
negative selection approach like Mouse
cell depletion or fax it was we were
able to get relatively pure populations
and so I said that we I would go back to
the question of
you know real-world example of using
these approaches and so we we looked we
sequenced a couple of patient-derived
xenograft either comparing the presort
input during a little frequency to the
variant allele frequencies of different
mutations called
in a sample that was purified by fax and
that's what's shown on the left here I
think you can see the dots that have
open circles here fall on the unity line
which means that those are mutations
that are called in both samples and
they're called with relatively similar
pairing a little frequencies losing
contrast to private mutations
they're called only in the input that
are shown in red and so they have
essentially no variant zero during a low
frequency in the fax which means they're
not detected but they're detected in the
input and these are represent 187 12
positive mutations in this one sample
compared to the nine true positive and
these false positives apparent mutations
are really just Mouse reads that are
mapping partially to the human reference
genome this is in contrast if you use a
mouse cell depletion kit and compare
this to fax you really see that they
perform equally well at removing these
Mouse cells and preventing this high
false positive detection rate and
probably the ideal way and the way that
we use this in the lab is is we we do
bowls of varying a little or we do both
a mouse cell depletion followed by a
hybrid genome alignment and that really
makes sure that you don't have any if
there's any residual nucleic acids they
don't they don't align spurious lis so
the data that I've shown so far has been
with a targeted sequencing panel but
we've used this on much larger genomic
territory here's a study that we did
using whole exome sequencing unpaired
PDX and I'm showing just the most common
mutations in panel a and the top left we
were able to do some other interesting
thing
with this as well including looking at
mutational signatures which are shown in
panel B comparing mutations called
between samples before and after
chemotherapy and in panel B we were able
to get reliable copy number calls using
this approach and what we really wanted
to use this for was to be able to build
a database of highly annotated patient
drive Sina graphs and our goal was to be
able to mimic the great cohorts of human
primary samples that are now available
and so we've been using the cbio portal
as kind of a warehouse for our data and
we're trying to build a very well
annotated public database of Zena grabs
the type of data that we can get from
this shows both clinical events which
can include surgery treatments treatment
timelines for the patients as well as a
genomic overview and includes copy
number changes and mutation calls
everything that I've shown so far has
been data that we've published I also
want to show a couple of slides of
unpublished data techniques that we're
starting to do in the lab using this
approach one is we're very interested in
the idea of in vivo genome engineering
of patient-derived xenograft and this
really depends on being able to get
reliable infection of lentiviruses into
cancer cells and so we begin with making
a single cell suspension from a
patient-derived xenograft we then remove
stroma and that's depicted here in the
middle the human fraction initially is
actually less than 25% in this
particular model but after we deplete
the mouse cell the mouse cells actually
end up being a minority cell population
and so this enriches for cells that we
actually want to infect with with
lentiviruses
we do an axial spin infection and then
as a proof of concept we infected the
suspension with a lentivirus that
expresses em Jerry I think you can
appreciate it you can get a significant
fraction of positive cells after this
you can even image this using optical
imaging techniques so this is kind of
our proof-of-concept pilot experiment
that that we could do this and we
started to think about other other
approaches that are you know what we
might be able to use this technology for
so one approaches then we've been
thinking about how we wanted to do or
how we'd like to use this for target
validation so we developed these
constructs that are similar to two other
contracts that have been used by other
groups that are Lenti viral vectors that
express either sacred any elisa phrase
or calculus if rays tied to the
expression of a shrna of interest and
what this allows you to do is look at
different luciferase expression as a
surrogate for that shrna and this allows
you to do clonal competition experiments
to compare the fitness of the gain or
loss of different genes so this the idea
here is basically at time zero I mean
you do a spin infection with lentivirus
and graft your tumors wait until the
tumors start to become established and
then you add dr. cycling which turns on
the shrna and turns on the luciferase
and then what we do is just measure
luciferase signal in these mice over
time which is shown here on the right
and the gap in the separate signal that
develops over time is really in an
indication of the fitness of the gain or
the loss of a specific gene so in this
example this is just showing a negative
control as they turn in a charging your
Anila versus a positive control that's
hard
our PA and we've also been thinking
about doing more exotic things so this
is a similar vector where instead of
instead of using luciferase we're now
bringing in the programmable nuclea is
kept nine and we wanted to be able to
select cells that actually expressed as
nine and we thought one nice approach to
be able to do this would be to use
immuno magnetic sorting so we created a
new type of reporter that's a cd4
protein that is truncated to have only
domain one and two and what this allows
us to do is use superparamagnetic beads
to pull out the cells that express this
truncated cd4 at the bottom here I'm
just showing a schematic of how this
experiment or work basically initially
we start with a PDX we infect with a
lentivirus shown in blue and then after
the next passage we do in the media
magnetic sorting and then an absence of
Doc's you don't get expression of test
nine but in the presence of Doc's you
get expression so this allows us to have
inducible genome editing in px and we've
done some pilot experiments to see just
how how much purity we can get from a
immune magnetic sorting approach such as
this and the x-axis here we basically
spike in a percentage of cells that are
positive for cd4 from the start and on
the y axis I'm showing the percentage of
cells that are positive for cd4 after I
mean a magnetic enrichment so the black
line is really just showing that when we
start with twenty percent or ten percent
cd4 positive cells after one enrichment
we can be higher than sixty percent or
higher than eighty percent so this was
just to prove to ourselves that we could
we could bring these cells purify these
cells out
I also just want to show a couple of
slides of unpublished data for some of
the single seller and they seek that
we've been doing you know if you want to
be able to do single flower I see it
helps to be able to get yourself into a
nice single cell suspension so we've
been collaborating this is data from
Ashley lost me from Tron messy gaze lab
and the sequencing and data analysis is
is done in collaboration with data pair
and what this is showing is a collection
of more than forty thousand cells from a
number of patients that we've been
sequencing and these are clusters using
a typical algorithm that's often used
for singles are any seed is for some
sometimes called a TCE plot and what
this is just showing is that the cells
that we're sequencing are not clustering
specifically by one patient these are
colored by individual patients and this
is knowing us that we're not getting a
lot of patients a patient variation or
that is that the patient patient
variation is not really driving that
variance here and so now this is the
same data but it's now instead of being
colored by patient it's being colored by
cell type and so we're pulling all
different kinds of cell types out of
this many of these are infiltrating
immune cells but many of these other
cell types are the cancer cells
themselves the way these break down is
the majority of cells that we're
sequencing here are the lymphoid cells
and glue at myeloid cells and this kind
of magenta color I think if we did more
of the sequencing we would probably
think about depleting a fraction of
these municipal trading cells so that we
could sequence a higher fraction of the
epithelial cells but this is just to
point out that we're able to really
characterize these individual cell
populations and I mentioned that you
know one of our key factors here is we
wanted we wanted to make sure
that weight from patient to patient the
variability that we're studying is the
biological variability and not you know
differences technical differences from
from sequencing around the sequencing
rod and so what I'm showing here is
again the the patient ID coloring on the
Left which is similar to which is
basically just showing again the data
from an earlier slide and then colored
by the Shannon diversity index which
gives us a sense for how different each
group is or how to for each single
sellers from neighbors and so you can
see that all of those cells were
previously colored as as lymphoid cells
are all mixing well together whereas the
components of this that are from the
epithelial cell compartment are the ones
with higher diversities the interesting
thing about this data if you look at the
violin plot at the bottom is that there
are two samples that have really very
low diversity this one shown in magenta
and then this other dark red sample and
these corresponds to these patients up
here and the interesting thing is that
these samples both come from metastatic
samples so this is telling us that
there's some metastatic there's some
bottlenecking that's happening that's
coincident with the metastatic process
so to summarize some of the what I just
told you is that we're using automated
Association to improve the consistency
within treatment groups for PDX studies
it allows for us for downstream sorting
applications that include flow cytometry
and immune of agentic enrichment or
depletion it can be used to generate
cell suspensions that are suitable for
virus infection and we also think you
know in our hands it's an ideal partner
for single-cell sequencing so with that
I'd be very happy to take questions for
people who are interested about these
topics and others related to patient dr
cena grafts excellent presentation dr.
Parr ei thanks for bringing that
information to us
before it gets started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll get to as many as we can our
first question is with the use of flow
cytometry in conjunction with single
cell dissociation make primary tumor
identification easier I think it has the
potential I think it would depend on
having good markers from you know
phenotyping for the particular type of
primary sample that you're trying to
identify I think one thing you lose when
you dissociate tumors is that you lose
all the morphological information that
you would have on the tumor that's been
sectioned so in some respects I mean
could be useful in other respects you
know you lose some information here from
a clinical perspective you know we're
working with minority of tumors where we
have fresh surgical or biopsy samples
available I think the majority of cases
you're working from FFPE and I think
that this technology wouldn't be
applicable in that case but in other
cases where you have fresh tissue and
good markers I think there's potential
there the presence of mouth stroma is in
the human cells and tissues enhance the
tumor key great that's a really good
question it's not something that that
we've looked at systematically yet I can
I can tell you that anecdotally when
we've purified just the human cancer
cells away by fax and then injected
those into a mouse they take very well
in the handful of samples that that
we've looked at and that sort of mirrors
the experience that that we have with
injecting cultured cell lines directly
that said we know that some PDX types
take better than others and some for
example different breast PDX require you
know addition of estradiol and and
things of that nature to help improve
the take rate so
there are certain sell extrinsic factors
that do matter I think one of a very
significant challenge in the future for
PDX
is going to be trying to you know
replicate a stromal environment that's
as close as possible to the human
environment in a mouse for example we
know that different growth factors don't
have activity cross reactivity between
between human and mouse and so you know
those factors and others probably play a
role in the differential take rate that
we see between different tumor types
that seem to be independent of
proliferation rate so I hope that's I
hope that's a useful answer but I can't
really give you a definitive answer
based on experimental evidence for my
group will this be available to trap
children as changes happen due to
infections environment etc to map the
genetic variance through time I think in
this case by children you mean
ancestrally for the tumor and if that's
the case we have tracked over multiple
passages for example tumor the amount of
tumor stromal is there a tumor stroma
that's there you know we have done
sequencing after multiple passages to
look at copy number and single
nucleotide variants if your question was
more related to clonal lineage tracing
with lentiviruses my group hasn't hasn't
done that but something we're interested
in doing and there are libraries that
are publicly available for example from
a gene to barcode and lineage trace
using integrating lentiviruses
have you compared orthotopic to
subcutaneous PDX and do you think clonal
parity with the original patient tumor
is influenced by orthotopic versus
subcutaneous mouse stroma this is
another great question we haven't again
we haven't looked at this systematically
in my group but I know that
there are some groups particularly
cellular in scigirl immunology I can't
quote the literature to you but they
have looked at the immune cell
infiltrates specifically in primary
tumor in subcutaneous flanks Nina grafts
versus orthotopic versus primary tumors
and there are significant differences
there the types of immune cell that
infiltrate and and their phenotype you
know we haven't looked specifically at
the clonal the clonal heterogeneity of
xena grafts at different sites but we do
know that there in metastatic sites you
do get clonal bottlenecking and we see
very significant differences in response
rate to different types of therapies
depending on the anatomical context so I
think it's an important question I think
it's a challenging one that my group
hasn't specifically addressed yet but I
think it should be done
does clonal hetero heterogeneity change
over time there are two gray papers that
I know about this subject one of them is
a little bit older it comes from it's in
a nature letter from Sam Ezio's group at
the University of British Columbia
they look specifically at breast cancer
patients Deena graphs at single-cell
resolution and they were able to see a
few different modes of clonal evolution
happening and some some PDX had
relatively stable clonal proportions
which suggested that maybe there wasn't
much selection going on while other PDX
saw significant selection of specific
clones that was reproducible in multiple
replicates that i think is a kind of a
hallmark paper in the literature there's
another paper in Nature Genetics the
most recent issue for Todd gallops group
they looked at
toom revolution specifically looking at
copy number alterations and more than a
thousand different PDX from 24 cancer
types so certainly that's one of the
more broad examples of looking at a
clonal evolution in these models I think
that you know their general conclusion
was that there is a mouse specific tumor
evolution process that's happening I
would encourage you to read through that
paper what system did you use for single
cell sequencing we have a few different
systems and approaches that we use but
the data that I showed here where we're
sequencing off our fresh cells is with
the 10x genomic system is it possible to
quantitate changes in gene expression
within the stromal cell component sure
so the data that I showed you here where
we aligned to the hybrid genome you know
we were really just interested in what
was happening in the human cell so we
just discard the reads that
preferentially map to the mouse genome
it would be perfectly reasonable to
count those reads and assign them
specifically to the mouse drama
are there special technical requirements
or challenges for aligning reads to
hybrid genomes I think this was
something that was more challenging to
do a few years ago than it is now the
major requirement is that for most
aligners the human reference and the
mouse reference have to both fit in
memory at the same time and that means
that the program that's doing the
aligning has to be able to address that
a chunk of memory that large and for for
example bwa which is the liner that we
used here it used to be only available
in a 32-bit application that was unable
to address the amount of memory required
to align against such a large reference
now there are binaries available for
that most operating systems and hardware
supports 64-bit but it's something that
you should be aware of and pay close
attention to with respect to the memory
requirements how do you screen for
cross-contamination of pdx samples and
avoid them this is a really critical
issue I think that there have been a few
papers kind of criticizing the
literature and the scientific community
for not paying enough attention to this
I think it's a major problem one thing
you know our approach used to be to take
a similar approach to selling
authentication using short tandem repeat
to try and you know get the identity of
different PBX I think the problem with
that is it's fairly expensive
I think commercially doing that it's
more than $100 per sampling we weren't
able to do that internally more recently
what we've been doing to check for major
contamination is to use snip qpcr essays
that in Drive on plates and PCR to
genotype between 8 and 16 snips from by
direct lysis from frozen vial so
basically you can scrape the vial do a
direct lysis to get the DNA out and then
and do a few different qPCR essays to
get the genotype this works for for
catching big this works for catching
kind of major contamination but it's not
very sensitive so I think you know one
thing we also pay very close attention
to is especially if we're concerned with
with with minor contamination is very
high depth sequencing of informative
variable snips so in the msk impact
assay that I told you about we capture
about a thousand specific snips and we
compare the gene sites to those snips to
the normal blood from that patient but
also to previous passages you can also
estimate whether there's minor
contamination based on based on those
snips in terms of the number of those
snips that have that are either
homozygous heterozygous or tri allelic
and so we pay we pay close attention to
that I think that probably in the future
people should start publishing these
snip fingerprints at least for 8 to 16
snips for PDX of these and publications
the next person says hi doctor prior it
was an excellent talk I work on PDX
samples and I grow stem cells in the
form of steroids from the cells isolated
from PDF samples I would like to know
how can we harvest these stem cells
steroids for RNA or protein by
effectively removing dead cells and then
there's another part of it too but
that's a tough question so my lab works
in with small cell lung cancer and and
they sell lines that are generated from
small cell lung cancer tend to grow on
these spheroids and and we recognize as
well that you have a lot of dead cells
at the center of these fjords that don't
get exposure to nutrients or they don't
get enough oxygen and maybe the
population that you're most interested
is in is the cells that are really at
the interface with the liquid medium I
can't give you a definitive answer but I
think that that one approach could be to
use flow sorting with a live dead die
and then sort the live cells directly
into tries all for RNA see that could be
that could be one approach I don't know
whether that would introduce additional
biases or but that's an approach that
we've used effectively for getting RNA
seek data from isolated immune cell
populations for example from flow
cytometry okay and here's the next part
of their question centrifugation at 49
grams leave its grams 49 G or histo pack
hasn't been very effective your
suggestion will be very valuable Thanks
I think I would stick with flow there
unless you have a unless the diffraction
of cells that you have is very very high
in terms of the percentage of dead cells
then you might consider maybe a two part
application where you could try to
remove dead cells by you know if I call
like you suggested
or maybe perhaps by an immuno magnetic
dead cell removal kit followed by fax I
think that would certainly be the way to
get you know pure single cells directly
into RNA see you know for I see could be
a sort them directly into tries all I
just want to say that oh here we go
another one so if she really passages
these primary tumors presumably the male
stroma is not metastatic and would die
when subsequently injected in following
passages guess it's a comment for you to
comment on I mean yes we believe that to
be the case so we've done experiments
where we infect a single cell suspension
that contains human and mouse cells with
a lentivirus
and when we passage that tumor and
dissociate a second time the only cells
in our marks with the lentivirus are the
human cells so we interpret that of
course there are other interpretations
where we interpret that to mean that you
know because of the hayflick limit and
and and the points that you've mentioned
that probably those cells are not
sticking around for many passages many
questions have come in so which we
didn't get to yours we will follow up
with you via
I would like to once again thank dr. JT
Poirier for his presentation and I would
like to thank our sponsor milton e
biotech for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you'll receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes calm you're welcome to Ford this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we will see you next time